[Music]
vanessa starts off this hour in los
angeles hi vanessa how are you
hi i'm doing fine how are you guys
better than we deserve what's up in your
world
thank you so much for taking my call so
um i have about three months of
expensive save so i'm in the middle of
baby step number three and i'm looking
to move out and i'm not sure if i should
be leaning towards renting an apartment
or working towards purchasing something
move out of your parents house
um well i rent a studio from my
grandparents house which is really small
and i don't have a kitchen so yeah i'm
looking to upgrade
okay and what do you make of your
65 000. okay
all right and you live in los angeles
proper or what
yes i live in los angeles by downtown
l.a okay all right
well as you know you're in a pretty
expensive real estate market agreed
yes i agree and um
so 65 000 doesn't go that far
you're not exactly broke you have a good
job but um but it's an expensive world
to try to think about rent or buying
either one in your situation
so you are did you say you're out of
debt
i am out of debt yes and i work from
home so i am like
flexible i can move out of la i don't
mind like leaving l.a i just you know
don't know
if it's the best thing to do what's the
comparison between what you're paying
for the studio with your grandparents
versus something else that's not
exorbitant or luxurious but
an apartment with a kitchen what's that
going to cost you in la
probably like another thousand dollars a
month compared to what i'm paying now
what do you pay now
i pay only like 350.
yeah if you can get that for 13.50 you
got a deal
that'd be a deal yeah um
yeah okay
um obviously your family is in l.a
how old are you
i'm 25. what do you do for a living
i work in fraud prevention for an
e-commerce business okay good for you
okay thank you um
okay so
here's the thing if you don't see your
income coming up
fairly quickly
you're going to struggle to own real
estate in l.a soon
it's gonna take a while
okay so i'm tempted
as a short-term adventure to move you to
a less expensive market as an adventure
not a permanent solution maybe maybe it
is a permanent solution
but pick a city you've always wanted to
live in and let's try something new
you're 25 is not much holding you except
family ties and let's go somewhere where
65 000 goes a lot further
yes i agree and then you could get a lot
of a little bit nicer rental situation
while you save like crazy to buy a
property um and then talk about as your
income comes up now if you tell me that
in
three years you're going to be making
165k then i'll shut up
but if you're going to be making 65 and
then 75 and then 85 you're going to be
there a while in la
yeah
so i'm not trying to talk you out of
this but it's just no matter what your
career path is because this is a math
thing and you don't get a pass on math
just because you're in california
and that's the question i have is what's
driving your future decision right now i
know it can change tomorrow but right
now is it
live in a more affordable place and keep
doing the kind of work i'm doing or is
there a much higher professional goal
that you're you're dreaming about
um i think right now it's just moving
into a more affordable place i just got
this job right so i was making 40k just
three months ago and i just received a
new job so now i'm like
good um
yeah i'm just ready to
move out and basically start my adult
life finally yeah well i agree with dave
i would be patient
and uh get into this new professional
role let's move to a much cheaper area
the fact that you're working from home
we say after christmas we start talking
about
moving to a different city
yeah that's what i was aiming towards
yeah let's just stay in the studio till
then
okay
that's what i would do because my
birthday my birthday is in march so i
was hoping like by march yeah you know
yeah and then you can move to what if
you were just going to pick a city today
just for fun for us to talk about what
city would you pick
well probably somewhere in riverside
county because i also have family out
there but i don't know if it's like a
lot of a difference in
like rent no not much
yeah that's not that's not really a
different city i mean that's just
that's moving from one problem to
another there but i mean if you went to
northern california uh into some of
those areas you know there's more
reasonable stuff going on there or you
just go to an adjacent state
you know yeah
we start talking about um tucson or
something like that i'm just making it
up okay but so you just start saying
okay by march i'm gonna be here
if i'm not seeing a huge increase in my
pay
boom over boom over boom
okay
because you in order to prosper in a
very very expensive market you're gonna
have to get north of six figures pretty
quick
okay
it's just a shovel thing i mean you got
a hole you're in and a shovel you to dig
with and that's what we're discussing
here so the good news is you're in an
area a field that you've chosen to go
into that if you'll get continue to
study take classes
get the certifications in that area
security internet security stuff is just
quite hot and you could go way up real
fast yeah i think there's three things
that i would give to her and anybody's
looking to kind of level up and get that
paycheck bigger learn something new
every day within the field i mean every
day you're learning something maybe it's
uh through a course or maybe it's just
somebody who's more experienced than you
do something with that knowledge and
make sure you're connecting all of the
time real relationships and real
conversations with people in the field
because by learning doing connecting
you're gonna automatically have
opportunities that come to you because
you're very attractive people can see
that your leadership sees that about you
and before you know it you're moving up
and you're making six figures and see
opportunities you never saw before
you might consider moving to the city
where this company is and working in the
office
because that way you can be actually
around the human beings that are doing
this it's um one of the problems with
work from home is out of sight out of
mind on promotions
uh they forget you're there
they're not even sure you are there
that's correct that is correct the data
is showing that uh as people are trying
to wrestle with whether or not i go back
to work or not the data shows that uh
there's a much greater chance of getting
promoted because you're actually getting
noticed yeah so here's a weird thing
promotions also happen on relationships
yes and that's not a good old boy
network it's just i can trust you if
i've actually seen your eyes